JOANNA SMITH: Hi.
I'm Joanna Smith.
And I'm going to show you how
to leverage the power of Google
to enhance product discovery,
increase basket size,
and create a seamless
omnichannel journey for grocery
shoppers.
COVID-19 has disrupted
how we approach
many of our regular tasks.
With grocery shopping,
a common errand
has been suddenly transformed
by safety concerns
and social distancing
requirements.
So it's no wonder that
online grocery shopping
is expected to accelerate
at a much higher rate
than previous years.
To set the scene
for this demo, I'm
going to take you through the
journey of a grocery shopper.
Remy lives in the city with
a stay-at-home advisory
and has been finding
ways to avoid going out.
This weekend he has plans
to do a virtual dinner
party with some friends,
where they will all
attempt to cook the same
meal over a video call.
To find a fun recipe, Remy
has been browsing YouTube
for ideas and inspiration.
He really likes
this homemade pizza
and checks the video description
for the recipe, where
he finds a link prompting
him to buy the ingredients
with Groceries For You.
This video happens to be a
co-promotion with a retailer.
And that link acts as
an entry point for Remy
to do his grocery shopping
online, making it easy for Remy
to shop for the
ingredients he will need.
In the Groceries
For You app, Remy
is brought directly
to the recipe card
for the pizza he was looking at.
Since he may already have
some of the ingredients,
he's offered an easy way to
select what he needs and then
add everything to his cart.
In the cart, he's
given the opportunity
to make modifications and
add additional items based
on personalized recommendations
powered by machine learning.
For example, he can select
a different mozzarella
from a brand he prefers.
He can add related
items and even add
some of his go-to favorites.
This experience was powered by
Google Cloud Recommendations
AI.
The retailer was able to offer
suggestions in several ways,
first by looking
at similar items
and providing
comparable products,
next by looking at
the customer's cart
and launching real-time
recommendations based
on selected items, and lastly,
by using historical user
data for predictive
replenishment suggestions.
With Recommendations
AI, retailers
don't need to build their
own machine learning models.
Instead they can plug their
product catalog and user
transaction data into existing
recommendations AI models
and be up and
running in no time.
Early results from retailers
using Recommendations AI
show success, with more than
a 40% increase in conversion
driven by recommendations,
leading to more than a
50% increase in revenue
driven by recommendations.
Remy is ready to
check out and selects
a window for curbside pickup
so that he can minimize
his exposure to other people.
He uses G Pay, where his
payment information is already
securely stored
and avoids having
to type out his credit
card information
on that mobile keyboard.
When he's ready to
pickup his order,
Remy can easily
navigate to the store
and even share his
location with the retailer
to expedite the pickup process.
Each of these pieces
offered a small improvement
that together created a seamless
journey for the customer.
Later on, Remy is wondering
what to do if an item was
out of stock for his order.
The app offers a
chat functionality.
So Remy asks about the safety
precautions the store has,
in case he needs to go inside.
The chat bot is able to
answer Remy's question
and explains the safety measures
the store has put in place.
This helps Remy feel better.
But he's hoping he
won't need to go inside.
So he asks the chat bot what
the process is for substituting
items in his order.
Again, the chat bot is is able
to answer Remy's question.
And Remy is reassured that
his order will be complete,
since he has not received a
message indicating otherwise.
This integrated digital
shopping assistant
is powered by Dialogflow,
the same technology that
supports Google Assistant.
Dialogflow can be
used to easily train
a chat bot to answer
common questions
or even provide item details
based on your product catalog.
At the store, the retailer
has mechanisms in place
to properly receive, execute,
and complete Remy's order.
A grocery agent
receives the order
and collects all of the items,
with guidance on specific aisle
and shelf locations, handling
instructions, and even
the ability to scan on the go.
Meanwhile, the store manager
can see data and metrics
for the entire store, including
information on gross sales
or the overall number of
orders received and completed
throughout the day.
By combining data from
various sources like this,
the store manager can
make informed decisions
for things like
scheduling or inventory,
leading to more
satisfied customers,
lower wait times, and
fewer out-of-stock alerts.
With this assisted
grocery experience,
Remy was able to go
from watching a YouTube
video of a recipe that
he liked to picking up
his groceries in a seamless
shopping experience.
By bringing together
consumer Google products,
like YouTube maps and G Pay,
and leveraging Google Cloud
solutions like Recommendations
AI and Contact Center AI,
we hope to help your business
create positive and profitable
user experiences.
To learn more about Google
Cloud's retail solutions,
check out cloud.google.com
/solutions/retail.
[MUSIC FADING OUT]